your hip consists of two main parts that
fit together like a ball and socket the
femoral head at the top of the leg and
the acetabulum in your pelvis
a total hip replacement is usually done
when severe damage from arthritis or
injury has made it difficult to perform
daily activities
during the procedure the femoral head
and acetabulum are replaced with
artificial components called prostheses
and artificial hip prosthesis consists
of a cup called the acetabular component
and a metal stem called the femoral
component
before your procedure you will receive
intravenous fluids antibiotics and
medications to help you relax a catheter
will be placed in your bladder to drain
your urine most hip replacements are
done under general anesthesia in which
case a breathing tube will be inserted
in your throat to help you breathe
during the operation since fluid and
blood loss can be significant banked
blood will be prepared in case you
require a transfusion you may have the
opportunity to collect and store your
own blood in preparation for your
surgery your surgeon will begin by
making an incision overlying your hip
separating the muscles and ligaments to
expose the joint capsule
after incising the capsule your surgeon
will dislocate the femoral head from the
acetabulum
he or she will remove any damaged
cartilage or bone in the acetabulum
reshape the acetabular socket and secure
the acetabular prosthesis in place using
special cement or screws turning next to
the femur your surgeon will remove the
femoral head shape the remaining femur
to fit the prosthetic stem and secure
the femoral component using cement or
other techniques once both components
are firmly in place your surgeon will
slide the prosthetic femoral head into
its acetabular counterpart test the
movement of your new hip joint and
verify that it is properly positioned
with an x-ray your surgeon will then
close the joint capsule repair the
muscles place a drain in your hip to
remove excess fluid and close the
incision with stitches or staples at the
conclusion of the operation a special
device will be temporarily applied to
prevent your hip from dislocating you
will then be moved to the post surgical
recovery area until you are stable and
awake from the anesthesia if necessary
you may receive a blood transfusion at
this time you will continue your IV
fluids and antibiotics for a short time
and will be given pain medications as
needed your catheter will likely be
removed after several days to prevent
blood clots from forming in your leg
you'll be given a blood thinner as to
where pneumatic compression stockings
and encouraged to begin walking as soon
as possible a nurse or physical
therapist will help you get out of bed
and use your new hip most patients are
released from the hospital once they are
able to walk with the aid of a crutch or
walker